We can't live without it. Most of us don't get enough of it. And when we don't, we get cranky, less productive, and more prone to health problems. I'm talking about sleep, of course. Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Do you remember the last time you woke up during the work week without an alarm clock when you didn't need caffeine to get going? If you can't, you're certainly not alone.
我们离不开睡眠。我们大多数人睡眠不足。当我们睡眠不足时，会变得脾气暴躁、效率降低，且更容易出现健康问题。当然，我指的是睡眠。大家好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。你还记得上一次在工作日不用闹钟自然醒，且不需要咖啡因提神是什么时候吗？如果你记不起来了，你绝对不是一个人。
Most of us fall short of the recommended 7 to 8 hours of sleep nightly, and an estimated 50 million to 70 million Americans of all ages in socioeconomic backgrounds suffer from sleep-related problems, according to the American Sleep Apnea Association. Our guest for this episode will give practical tips for getting a good night's sleep and explain how common mental health disorders can interfere with our much-needed shut-eye. Dr. Robin Haidt is a clinical psychologist in private practice in Virginia who specializes in treating anxiety, depression, and sleep issues. Welcome, Dr. Haidt. Thank you for having me.
根据美国睡眠呼吸暂停协会的数据，我们大多数人每晚的睡眠时间都达不到建议的7到8小时，估计有5000万到7000万不同年龄和社会经济背景的美国人受到睡眠相关问题的困扰。本期节目的嘉宾将提供获得良好睡眠的实用建议，并解释常见的心理健康障碍如何干扰我们急需的休息。罗宾·海特博士是一位在弗吉尼亚州私人执业的临床心理学家，专门治疗焦虑、抑郁和睡眠问题。欢迎您，海特博士。谢谢你邀请我。
We're very happy to have you on the show today. Can you explain some of the most common sleep issues you see with clients in your practice? By far, the most common complaint that I hear is that people have trouble falling asleep. That's called sleep initiation. And most of the time, they're saying that they have racing thoughts. are just not being able to shut off their brain. So how do you address that? I mean, how do you shut off your brain
很高兴您今天能来参加节目。您能解释一下您在执业过程中遇到的客户最常见的睡眠问题吗？到目前为止，我听到的最常见的抱怨是人们难以入睡。这被称为入睡困难。大多数时候，他们说自己思绪万千，就是无法让大脑停下来。那么您是如何解决这个问题的呢？我是说，当大脑高速运转时，你如何让它停下来？
when it's just going a million miles an hour? Do you get up? Do you change positions? Read a book, turn on the TV, start texting your friends. Well, let's back up maybe 30 minutes before all of this happens because a lot of times when I hear people talk about falling asleep and I always ask about sleep
当它以每小时一百万英里的速度运转时，你会起床吗？你会变换姿势吗？看书、打开电视、开始给朋友发短信。好吧，让我们回到这一切发生前的30分钟，因为很多时候，当人们谈论入睡时，我总是会询问睡眠情况。
when someone comes in to talk to me about anything. I always ask, you know, how are you sleeping these days? What I often find out is a lot of people have very poor sleep routines or get sleep hygiene, we tend to call it, you know, preparing for sleep. Or they may have sort of different kinds of attitudes about sleep, such as thinking that sleep is optional, not integral to mental health or physical health. And so I start to uncover some of these problems. that happen even before they get into bed in terms of their attitudes or their sleep hygiene.
当有人来找我谈论任何事情时，我总是会问：“你最近睡得怎么样？”我经常发现，很多人有非常糟糕的睡眠习惯，或者我们称之为“睡眠卫生”，也就是为睡眠做准备。或者他们对睡眠持有不同的态度，比如认为睡眠是可有可无的，而不是心理健康或身体健康不可或缺的一部分。因此，我开始揭示一些在他们上床睡觉前就存在的问题，这些问题与他们的态度或睡眠卫生有关。
So what is good sleep hygiene? Well, again, we have to back up at least 30 minutes, preferably an hour before you really want to go to bed or before you want to go to sleep, let's say. And having a good routine that kind of helps you separate the day from bedtime. And that doesn't include watching a scary movie and then turning it off and then expecting to go right to sleep. Yeah, right. That makes sense. You know, things like that are going to really jazz you up are going to be overstimulating, things that are going to kind of, you know, maybe having an intense conversation with your partner, with your kids, or, you know, things like that. Really, you got to keep that stuff in mind
那么，什么是良好的睡眠卫生呢？同样，我们必须回到至少30分钟，最好是在你真正想上床睡觉或想入睡前的一小时。拥有一个良好的作息习惯有助于你将白天与睡前时间区分开来。这并不包括看一部恐怖电影，然后关掉它，却指望能立刻入睡。是的，没错。这很有道理。你知道，像那样的事情会让你非常兴奋，会过度刺激你，或者可能与你的伴侣、孩子进行激烈的谈话，诸如此类的事情。真的，当你考虑睡眠并真正保护你的睡眠时，你必须记住这些。
when you think about sleep and, you know, really being protective of your sleep. I hear a lot about not using a screen before bed. So, you know, putting your smartphone thrown away, maybe even putting it in another room might be helpful. So do you tell people to really minimize screen time as you approach that hour before you go to sleep? Definitely. I mean, this is now, you know, five years ago, I was sort of informing people about this. Now people seem to know that screens, you know, and now you can buy blue light filtering glasses so people can still be on their phones right before bed because they think that if they just filter out the blue light, that that's good enough. But I really do try to get people to get off their screens, a good 30 to 60 minutes before
我经常听说睡前不要使用屏幕。所以，把你的智能手机收起来，甚至把它放在另一个房间可能会有帮助。那么，你是否告诉人们在临睡前的那一小时内尽量减少屏幕时间呢？当然。我是说，五年前我还在向人们普及这一点。现在人们似乎知道屏幕（的影响了），而且现在你可以买到防蓝光眼镜，所以人们在睡前仍然可以玩手机，因为他们认为只要过滤掉蓝光就足够了。但我确实尽量让人们在睡前30到60分钟远离屏幕。
going to bed. But the problem is a lot of people use their phones for their alarm clock. So it's probably not realistic to say, leave your phone in the kitchen. But, you know, sometimes it's just reminding people, like, get off your phone. Don't watch videos on your phone. Don't watch videos on your phone until you until right before bed or don't watch TV shows on your computer, on your laptop right before going to bed because those kinds of things really do suppress the melatonin that you, that your brain produces to help you start to feel sleepy. So it really is important to not have any close screen devices right before going to bed. Right. And you said it can be difficult as you, you know, if you do use it for your alarm clock, if it's the only clock in your room,
但问题是，很多人用手机当闹钟。所以说“把手机留在厨房”可能不太现实。但是，有时只是提醒人们：放下手机。不要在睡前一直看手机视频，或者不要在睡前在电脑或笔记本电脑上看电视节目，因为这些东西确实会抑制大脑产生的有助于你开始感到困倦的褪黑素。所以，在睡前不使用任何近距离屏幕设备确实很重要。没错。你说过，如果你用它当闹钟，如果它是你房间里唯一的时钟，这可能会很困难。
you might be thinking, oh, I have that last text message I need to send before I go to bed, but as much as you can, just try not to have your phone. Yeah, just as much as you can. I mean, I even look at my phone right before I go to bed sometimes that I think, I know I shouldn't be doing this. Yeah, it's hard, it's hard. But I want to check out this Instagram feed, you know. Yeah, right.
你可能会想，哦，我睡前还有最后一条短信要发，但尽可能尝试不要使用手机。是的，尽可能尝试。我有时甚至在睡前也会看手机，我想，我知道我不应该这样做。是的，这很难，很难。但我就是想刷一下Instagram。是的，没错。
I mean, just like I think of things as you're about to go to bed for the night. So you talk about how you, when then you're, see your clients, no matter what they come in, you ask about sleep. So can you talk about the mental health benefits of sleep? Sleep is still not entirely understood and why we need sleep. I mean, it's been studied for a long, long time, and then the research is ongoing. But what we have seen in some recent research is how sleep helps us build up long-term memories and helps us sort of consolidate our learning during the day or to process what we've been through during the day.
我是说，就像你在准备睡觉时想到的事情一样。所以你谈到无论客户为什么来找你，你都会询问睡眠情况。那么你能谈谈睡眠对心理健康的好处吗？人们对睡眠以及为什么我们需要睡眠仍然没有完全了解。我的意思是，它已经被研究了很长很长时间，而且研究仍在进行中。但我们在最近的一些研究中看到的是，睡眠如何帮助我们建立长期记忆，帮助我们整理白天的学习内容，或者处理我们白天经历的事情。
It also helps it build cognitive and emotional reserves. We also know that if you don't sleep, you have a lot of physical problems too. Like there was this research, a study done where animals that were deprived of entirely, deprived entirely of sleep, lost all immune function. And they died within a matter of weeks. Now, we couldn't necessarily deprive a human of sleep entirely to cause them to go, you know, to lose all of their immune function. But sleep is such an important thing for learning, for keeping emotional regulation. And all of us know how if we go to bed and we're in a bad mood, we're thinking about something that's upsetting.
它还有助于建立认知和情感储备。我们还知道，如果你不睡觉，也会有很多身体问题。比如曾有一项研究，将完全剥夺睡眠的动物的免疫功能全部丧失了。它们在几周内就死亡了。当然，我们不能为了让一个人失去所有免疫功能而完全剥夺他的睡眠。但睡眠对于学习和保持情绪调节非常重要。我们都知道，如果我们上床睡觉时心情不好，或者在想一些令人心烦的事情。
some if we have a good night's sleep it may not be that is that upsetting the next day yeah i definitely do feel like that you also kind of feel like you've kind of feel like you've a clean slate when you wake up in the morning if you've if you've if you've slept well of course of that whatever it was bothering you didn't keep you up in the night i notice a physical feeling which is i'm sure many people do as well like you just feel better in the morning knowing your your brain just like you said consolidated your memories kind of processed what you went through during the day and you feel more refreshed yeah yeah it's It's kind of mysterious, isn't it? You know, in eight hours, you could have a completely different perspective.
如果我们睡个好觉，第二天可能就不会那么心烦了。是的，我确实有这种感觉。如果你睡得好，早上醒来时也会感觉像是有了一个新的开始。当然，前提是困扰你的事情没有让你彻夜难眠。我注意到一种身体上的感觉，我相信很多人也有同感，就像你早上感觉更好，因为正如你所说，你的大脑整理了记忆，处理了你白天经历的事情，你感觉更清爽了。是的，这有点神秘，不是吗？你知道，在八小时内，你可能会有完全不同的视角。
And sometimes a good night's sleep even helps you think of alternatives to problems that you didn't even, you weren't even able to see the night before. I don't want to be like, oh, just get a good night's sleep and all your problems will be solved. But, you know, sleeping does help with giving us the energy and the just sort of this emotional. space to allow for other options to enter our minds. Yeah, absolutely. And on that note, I did an episode in January of 2019 about dreaming. So we were just very focused on dreaming. And the psychologist I interviewed Dr. Deerja Barrett.
有时睡个好觉甚至能帮你想到前一天晚上根本无法看到的解决问题的替代方案。我不想说“哦，睡个好觉，你所有的问题都会解决”。但是，睡眠确实有助于给我们提供能量和那种情感空间，让其他选择进入我们的脑海。是的，绝对是这样。顺便提一下，我在2019年1月做过一期关于梦的节目。所以我们非常专注于梦。我采访的心理学家迪尔贾·巴雷特博士。
She talked about how people say, how can I remember my dreams more? And she said, what I tell them is just you get more sleep. If you want to remember dreams, you have to get more sleep. You allow your brain to get into REM, to get into the really deep. deep sleep. And so that's talked about the importance of that in terms of being able to remember your dreams and, you know, take advantage of what they might be trying to tell you. Given how you are, you treat a lot of clients or an expert on anxiety and depression. Can you talk about the relationship between depression and sleep and anxiety and sleep? Yeah. You know, there's actually a lot of
她谈到人们问：“我怎样才能更多地记住我的梦？”她说，我告诉他们的是：多睡觉。如果你想记住梦，你必须多睡觉。你要让你的大脑进入快速眼动期（REM），进入非常深沉的睡眠。所以这就是谈论它的重要性，以便能够记住你的梦，并利用它们可能试图告诉你的信息。鉴于你治疗很多客户，并且是焦虑和抑郁方面的专家。你能谈谈抑郁与睡眠、焦虑与睡眠之间的关系吗？是的。实际上，失眠的症状与抑郁或焦虑的症状之间有很多重叠。
overlap in the symptoms between insomnia and the symptoms of depression or anxiety, like fatigue being one, obviously that's an obvious one, but loss of interest in stuff you're normally, you know, interested in, worrying, poor concentration, loss of motivation, even kind of suicidal thoughts or thoughts of like, I can't go on. Those symptoms can appear in both insomnia and depression or anxiety. And in fact, 80% of people with depression report problems with sleep. So it's really, important to tease out whether it's we're dealing with insomnia or if we're dealing with some sort of depressive episode. So what do you recommend if you are experiencing insomnia? Do you recommend that someone go see their primary hair physician? Should they seek out mental health services?
比如疲劳是一个明显的症状，还有对平时感兴趣的事物失去兴趣、担忧、注意力不集中、动力丧失，甚至出现自杀念头或“我无法继续下去”的想法。这些症状可能同时出现在失眠、抑郁或焦虑中。事实上，80%的抑郁症患者报告有睡眠问题。因此，弄清楚我们面对的是失眠还是某种抑郁发作非常重要。那么，如果你正在经历失眠，你有什么建议吗？你建议去看初级保健医生吗？他们应该寻求心理健康服务吗？
You know, most people wait months or even years of having poor sleep before they even seek help. They just learn to live with it or they tell themselves, you, you, you, you, probably have heard people say, I'm not a good sleeper. And they think that that's an okay thing to say. So they have this narrative that they just sort of live with, like, yeah, you know, I toss and turn, or my partner says that I wake up a lot at night. And they just live with it. So after folks have really decided that they want to address their insomnia, which for many people can take months or years for them to get to that point. I always start with, you know, how long has it been since you've seen your doctor? Or have you seen your doctor? Have you told your doctor about this? Because I
你知道，大多数人在寻求帮助之前，已经忍受了几个月甚至几年的糟糕睡眠。他们只是学会了忍受，或者他们告诉自己——你可能也听过人们说——“我睡眠不好”。他们认为这没什么大不了的。所以他们有这样一种叙述，就像“是的，你知道，我辗转反侧，或者我的伴侣说我晚上醒来很多次”。他们就这样忍受着。所以，在人们真正决定要解决失眠问题后（对许多人来说，达到这一点可能需要几个月或几年），我总是从“你有多久没看医生了？”或者“你看过医生了吗？你告诉过医生了吗？”开始。因为我
definitely want their physician to rule out any medical issues. And there can be some medical issues. Or medications can affect how you're sleeping. There are antihistamines that can affect your sleeping. Some people are taking antidepressants and that can affect their sleeping. And asthma medicine, steroids, these things all can affect sleeping. And it's not that you shouldn't take any of those drugs. It's just maybe you just need to tinker with when you take them. So I definitely want the medical side of things to be kind of in order so that we can start talking about their beliefs and their attitudes about sleeping and their sleep hygiene, their preparation for sleep. because that would be my role in helping people to address any problems that they have with
绝对希望他们的医生排除任何医疗问题。可能会有一些医疗问题。或者药物会影响你的睡眠。有些抗组胺药会影响睡眠。有些人正在服用抗抑郁药，这也会影响睡眠。还有哮喘药、类固醇，这些都会影响睡眠。并不是说你不应该服用这些药物，只是也许你需要调整服药时间。所以我绝对希望医疗方面的问题得到妥善处理，这样我们才能开始讨论他们对睡眠的信念和态度，以及他们的睡眠卫生，即为睡眠所做的准备。因为这就是我的角色，帮助人们解决他们可能存在的任何失眠问题。
insomnia. A couple of things I want to do is, are they going to bed, do they have good sleep hygiene, and are they going to bed at a regular time, do they have a pretty regular sleep-wake schedule? The other thing that I would want to address is, are they getting enough light during the day? That may sound sort of odd or weird to some people, but having being exposed to natural light throughout the day, at least a few, you know, a few minutes, a few times a day really help set your biological clock. And people who go from their house to their car, to a garage, to their office that may not
我想做的几件事是：他们是否在睡觉？他们是否有良好的睡眠卫生？他们是否在固定的时间上床睡觉？他们是否有相当规律的睡眠-觉醒时间表？我想解决的另一件事是：他们白天是否有足够的光照？这对某些人来说可能听起来有点奇怪，但在白天接触自然光，每天几次，每次几分钟，确实有助于设定你的生物钟。而那些从家里到车里，到车库，再到办公室（可能没有窗户），然后再回家的人，可能没有获得足够的自然光。
have a window, and back again to home may not be getting enough natural light. especially in the winter yeah especially in the winter exactly and people don't tend to go out for walks in the winter but one thing i do tell people is i don't care what the temperature is or what the even if it's raining you know just go stand outside under you know under an awning or something even just for 10 15 minutes or walk around the block it's really important because that natural light sets your brain to this is when I'm awake. And being awake, being fully awake during the day and having your brain register that is going to help you fall asleep at night. Yes. What I'm hearing is that it's important to recognize that your issues with sleeping may be for a variety of reasons.
特别是在冬天。是的，特别是在冬天。没错，人们冬天往往不出去散步。但我告诉人们的一件事是：我不在乎温度是多少，即使是在下雨，你知道，只要去外面站在遮阳篷下或类似的地方，哪怕只是待10到15分钟，或者绕着街区走一圈。这真的很重要，因为自然光会向你的大脑设定“这是我清醒的时间”。白天保持清醒，并让你的大脑记录下来，这将有助于你晚上入睡。是的。我听到的是，重要的是要认识到你的睡眠问题可能是由多种原因造成的。
And that's important to figure out exactly and drilled on exactly what is causing the issue. Yeah. Yeah. And first and foremost, we need to get any kind of medical issue sort of taken care of people who don't sleep very well and who sort of live with it may not be going to their doctor or may not tell their doctor. But once all of that stuff is squared away or is being addressed on the medical side of things, I definitely want to make sure that their behaviors are conducive to having good sleep. And then after the behaviors, we also want to talk about what attitudes they're having about sleep. Is sleep optional for them? Or do they keep telling themselves this narrative like, oh, I'm just not a good sleeper?
弄清楚到底是什么导致了问题非常重要。是的。首先，我们需要处理任何医疗问题。睡眠不好且忍受它的人可能没有去看医生，或者没有告诉医生。但一旦所有这些事情都理顺了，或者在医疗方面得到了解决，我绝对想确保他们的行为有助于获得良好的睡眠。在行为之后，我们还要谈谈他们对睡眠的态度。睡眠对他们来说是可有可无的吗？或者他们是否一直对自己说这种叙述，比如“哦，我只是睡眠不好”？
Or my mother was never a good sleeper. My dad was never a good sleeper and neither am I. Or that having these faulty beliefs that if they have a bad night sleep that, you know, that's going to make them really anxious and they're not going to be able to function. And so they might be laying there at night trying to fall asleep and then realizing that they're not falling asleep and then start getting themselves really anxious about not falling asleep, which in turn makes them less likely to fall asleep. And it becomes this really kind of maladaptive kind of pattern and a cycle, just a bad cycle to get in. So a lot of work I also do is in addressing those faulty beliefs about sleep and helping them to not become anxious about being anxious about their sleep.
或者“我母亲睡眠一直不好，我父亲睡眠一直不好，我也不好”。或者持有这些错误的信念：如果他们睡了个糟糕的觉，那会让他们非常焦虑，无法正常工作。于是他们可能晚上躺在那里试图入睡，然后意识到自己睡不着，就开始因为睡不着而变得非常焦虑，这反过来又使他们更难入睡。这变成了一种非常适应不良的模式和循环，一个糟糕的循环。所以我所做的大量工作也是在解决这些关于睡眠的错误信念，帮助他们不要因为对睡眠的焦虑而变得焦虑。
So how do you do that? Because I find myself doing that as you look at the clock, you're like, oh my gosh, if I don't fall asleep now, I'm only going to get five hours of sleep. Or, you know, you start off with eight hours. I'm only going to get eight hours. Oh, I'm only going to get seven. Only going to get six. How do you calm your mind during those moments when it's just running crazy, running a million miles a minute? The first thing I tell everybody who tells me that they have sleep problem, a sleep problem is don't look at the clock. And in fact, if they can turn the clock away from them or turn it, some clocks have a brightness feature where you can just turn it all the way down so you can't see it. Because looking at the clock and doing the
那么你是怎么做到的呢？因为我发现自己也会那样，当你看着时钟，你会想：“天哪，如果我现在不睡着，我只能睡五个小时了。”或者，你从八小时开始，“我只能睡八小时了。哦，我只能睡七小时了。只能睡六小时了。”当你的大脑疯狂运转，每分钟跑一百万英里时，你如何让它平静下来？我告诉每一个告诉我他们有睡眠问题的人的第一件事就是：不要看时钟。事实上，如果他们能把时钟转过去，或者——有些时钟有亮度调节功能，你可以把它调到最低，这样你就看不见了。因为看着时钟并计算“哦，离闹钟响还有5小时36分钟”，这根本没用。即使离闹钟响只剩下36分钟，继续休息也比不休息强。最近有一条新闻，就在本周或上周，关于人们佩戴的监测睡眠质量的健身追踪器。我不戴，所以我不知道它们具体监测什么。实际上，那些睡眠追踪功能已经成为一些人的压力来源。真的吗？是的。
calculus about, oh, I have five hours and 36 more minutes before the, you know, it's not going to help you. Even if you have only 36 more minutes before the alarm goes up, it's still not going to help you to continue resting. And then a recent piece of news came out just this week or last week about the fitness trackers that people sleep with that monitor how much they're sleeping and so on. I don't wear one of them so I don't know exactly what they monitor. That actually those sleep tracker functions have become a source of stress for some people. Really? Yeah.
所以，我认为任何这种监测实际上对很多人获得安稳的睡眠都是适得其反的。或者我应该说，对于获得“不焦虑”的睡眠是适得其反的。我们所做的任何增加对睡眠焦虑的事情，都不会让你感到困倦。所以，不看时钟，还有其他事情可以做吗？比如，你还能做些什么放松的事情来让大脑平静下来，而不涉及像看屏幕那样会刺激你的事情？是的。嗯，做一些睡前阅读，只要你读的不是太恐怖或太令人心烦的内容。这是人们做的我认为非常有帮助的事情。即使他们只是读10分钟，看一本杂志，读一本小说。有些人喜欢在床上做拼图，比如数独游戏，或者那种稍微有点刺激但不太费脑子的事情。
And so any of this sort of monitoring, I think, actually is counterproductive for a lot of people to getting restful sleep. Or I should say from getting non-anxious kinds of sleep. Anything we do to increase our anxiety about sleeping is not going to help you be sleepy. So not turning the clock, you know, not looking at the clock, are there other things you could do? Like, what other relaxing things can you do to calm your mind that don't involve something that would stimulate you like looking at a screen? Yeah. Well, doing things like reading before bed, as long as you're not reading something too scary or too upsetting, you know, just. And that's something that people do that I think really does is very helpful. Even if they do, even if they do, just read for 10 minutes, look at a magazine, read a novel. Some people do like puzzles in bed, like little Sudoku puzzles or sort of like mildly stimulating but, you know, not too taxing kind of thing.
也许对某些人来说，填字游戏也能放松。真正重要的是有一个相当规律的时间表，我认为这对很多人来说很难。你知道，特别是如果你有不规律的工作时间表。有些人需要轮班，然后在周末又得调整回来。所以这确实很难做到。但这就是使用光疗法可以重置你的时间表的时候。是的，我最近也做了一期关于季节性情感障碍的节目。我采访的专家凯利·罗恩博士，她谈到光疗法时，你确实需要……
Maybe even crossword puzzles for some people could be relaxing. Really the important thing is to have a pretty regular schedule, which I think is hard for a lot of people. You know, especially if you have kind of an erratic work schedule. Some people have work shifts and then they have to shift back on the weekends. So it is a hard thing to do. But that's when using light therapy can reset your schedule. Yeah, I did a recent episode as well on seasonal affective disorder. And the expert I spoke with Dr. Kelly Rowan, she talked about how with light therapy you do really need to be,
就人造光而言，不是外面的自然光，但她谈到了通过心理健康专业人士进行光疗的重要性，以确保你获得正确、适当的剂量，而不是让自己保持太长时间的清醒，或者因为过多的光照而过度刺激。没错，没错。是的，重要的是——我猜她在节目中也提到了这一点——你在一天中适当的时间使用这些光疗设备，不要在一天中太晚的时候使用它们。除非你真的想调整你的睡眠时间表。但那是另一个话题了。是的，她谈到只是确保你通过专业渠道。我的意思是，她谈论的是患有季节性情感障碍的人。所以这有点不同。
in terms of a manufacturer light, not natural light outside, but she talked about the importance of going through a mental health professional for that to make sure you're getting the right appropriate doses and not making keeping yourself up too much or being too stimulated by too much light. Right, right. Yeah, it is important to, and I'm guessing she covered this on that episode that that you use those light devices at the appropriate time of day, that you don't use them too late in the day. unless you're really trying to shift your sleep schedule. But that's a different topic altogether. Yeah, she talked about just making sure you're going through. I mean, she was talking about people who have seasonal affective disorder. So it's a little bit different.
但这与确保你的身体自然节律、让你的身体进入更好的时间表有关。这样你就可以起床开始你的一天，走出家门。所以它与睡眠有关，但属于不同的领域。你知道，有些人认为如果他们喝一杯，比如睡前喝一杯葡萄酒或睡前酒，会有帮助。人们过去常这样称呼它。它确实能让你睡几个小时，但酒精实际上可能会适得其反。它往往会在半夜把人唤醒，
But it's like in relation to like making sure your, you know, your body's natural rhythms, you're getting them getting your body on a better schedule. So you can get up and go about your day and get out of the house. And so it's related to sleep, but it's kind of a different area. You know, some people think that if they take, for example, if they take, you know, if they have a drink before bed, like a glass of wine or a nightcap. People used to call it that that will help. And it actually does make you sleep for a couple of hours, but alcohol actually can backfire. And it tends to wake people up in the middle of the night
因为它会增加新陈代谢。我确实尝试建议人们在睡前避免饮酒，你知道，至少在睡前几个小时就停止饮酒。吃大餐也是一样。你不想在离睡觉太近的时候吃大餐，因为它会增加你的新陈代谢。是的，因为你在消化。那么其他助眠药物呢，比如非处方药，像褪黑素，或者需要处方的东西？那些能帮你入睡吗？褪黑素是一种非常安全的东西。我确实建议人们尝试一下，看看它是否有帮助。许多人确实认为它有帮助。使用褪黑素真的没有副作用。
because it increases their metabolism. And it really is a thing that I try to recommend people avoid before bed is, you know, drinking alcohol, you know, kind of cut that off at least a couple of hours before bed. The same thing with having a heavy meal. You don't want to have that too close to bedtime because it's going to increase your metabolism. Yeah, as you're digesting. What about other sleep aids, like the more mild things that can get over the counter like melatonin or something that require a prescription? Do those help you sleep? Melatonin is a really safe thing. I do recommend that people check it out and see if it can help them. Many people do think it does help them. And there really are no side effects from using melatonin.
所以如果你觉得确实想吃点什么，这是一个风险很低的初步尝试。很多处方药，比如你可以从医生那里得到的催眠药或苯二氮卓类药物，我认为它们对于短期使用和受控使用是非常有用的。你知道，我见过很多人服用安必恩（Ambien）或其他助眠药长达多年，你可能会对它们产生依赖，或者会有副作用，比如梦游，或者因为长期使用这些药物而产生其他某种睡眠问题。但我认为医生通常会说，如果你正在经历人生中压力很大的时期，或者如果你有某些干扰睡眠的医疗问题，使用处方助眠药有时确实很重要，只要你不要长期依赖它。因为实际上睡眠更重要，在很多情况下这是一种成本效益分析。
So that's a pretty low risk first step if you feel like you do want to take something. A lot of the prescription medications, the hypnotics or the benzodiazepines that you can get from your physician can have, I think that they're really useful for a short-term use and monitored use. you know, I've seen a lot of people take things like Ambien or other sleep aids for years and years and years and years and you can become dependent on them or there are those side effects where people have, you know, sleep walking or, you know, just some sort of other kinds of sleep problems because of the long-term use of those things. But I think the doctors generally say that using a prescription sleep aid, is sometimes really important if you're going through some stressful periods in your life or if you have certain medical issues that are interfering with your sleep, as long as you're just not becoming dependent on it for a long, long time. Because actually sleep is more important than it's a cost-benefit analysis in a lot of situations.
因为如果你是一个非常焦虑的人，如果你正在经历人生中非常焦虑的时期，最好能有良好的睡眠，这样你才能应对压力，然后再处理药物问题。但这不是我能开处方的东西，所以我不会和我的客户深入探讨处方药。我尝试专注于更全面的方法，比如他们对睡眠的认知态度，确保他们重视睡眠，确保他们不会因为失去睡眠而变得焦虑，确保他们进行其他有助于睡眠的健康行为，比如锻炼。我不知道你怎么样，但我知道在我锻炼的日子里，我总是睡得更好。所以对我来说，这是显而易见的。
Because if you are a very anxious person, if you're going through a really anxious time of life, it's better to have good sleep so that you can deal with the stresses and then deal with the medication later on. But that's not something I can prescribe so I don't get into the prescription medications very deeply with my clients. I try to focus on the more holistic, the sort of cognitive attitudes that they have about sleep, making sure that they value sleep, making sure they don't become anxious about losing sleep, making sure that they do other healthy behaviors that will promote sleep like exercise. I don't know about you, but I know that on the days when I exercise, I always sleep better. And so to me, that's a no-brainer.
而且不需要大量的锻炼。即使你只是去散步10或15分钟，也能产生影响。是的，绝对是这样。所以，对于那些可能需要助眠药的人来说，听起来它们可能在短期内有帮助，但长期来看不是个好主意。但人们去看初级保健医生或精神科医生，或者能开处方的人仍然很重要。没错。但我认为正如你提到的，你不仅关注急性问题，还关注干扰睡眠的思维模式。所以这对于长期成功和获得良好的睡眠确实非常重要。是的，绝对是这样。所以我想回到你之前说的关于保持相同睡眠时间、在同一时间上床睡觉、在同一时间起床的重要性。我知道理论上听起来很棒。我知道你刚才提到了一些人可能面临的挑战，比如轮班工作，或者……
And it doesn't take a lot of exercise. Even if you just go on a walk for 10 or 15 minutes, that can make a difference. Yeah, absolutely. And so, you know, for someone who might, sleep aids, it sounds like they might help in the short term, long term, not a good idea. But it's still important for people to see a primary care physician or a psychiatrist, something who could prescribe the medication. Exactly. But I think it's important, as you mentioned, too, you're focusing not just on the acute issue, but also the, you know, thought patterns that are interfering with sleep likely. So that's really important in terms of long-term success and getting a good night's sleep. Yeah, definitely. So I want to go back to what you're saying before about the importance of having those same sleep going to bed at the same time, waking up at the same time. I know in theory that sounds great. I know you just mentioned some challenges people might have who work different shifts or, you know,
或者也许你只是想在周六晚上做点让你晚归的事情。那么，每天都有相同的睡眠和起床时间现实吗？这可能并不现实。我的意思是，如果你想和朋友出去玩，直到午夜或两点，你未必想在做完这些后在早上8点起床。我认为你必须真正相信你的身体。你的身体确实是你最好的向导。事实上，周末睡懒觉的人，即使你没有熬夜，你可能只是想在周六早上或周日早上，或者无论哪天是你的周末，睡个懒觉。
or maybe you just simply want to do something that keeps you out later in the night on the Saturday. So is it realistic to have those same, you know, same sleep and wake times every day? It's probably not realistic, actually. I mean, you know, if you're wanting to go out with your friends and you're, you know, out until midnight or two or whatever in the morning, and you don't want to get up at 8 a.m. after doing that necessarily. I think you have to really just trust your body on these things. Your body is really going to be your best guide. And actually, people who sleep in on the weekends, even if you're not staying up late, you might just want to sleep in on Saturday morning or Sunday morning or whatever days. your weekend falls.
周末睡懒觉实际上可能比睡眠数量更能帮助你补足睡眠质量。所以是有办法补回来的。是的，是的。你知道，人们在工作周期间，有时睡眠质量稍微差一点。他们可能没有获得他们需要的质量，那种深度的、好的深度睡眠，那种深度REM睡眠。而在周六或周日早上多睡一小时或一个半小时，会有很大的不同。
And sleeping on the weekends might actually help you catch up on the quality of your sleep, even more than the quantity of your sleep. So there is a way to catch up. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, people, during the work week, sometimes people are a little less restful in their sleep. And they might not get the quality, the deep, you know, the good deep sleep, the deep REM sleep that they need. and being able to have that extra hour in the morning or hour and a half on a Saturday or Sunday morning can make a lot of difference.
午睡呢？你认为午睡有益吗？它们能算作你晚上的睡眠吗？好的。午睡有点棘手，因为如果你确实患有失眠症，那是一个完整的诊断过程，我们需要确保：这是失眠吗？这是焦虑吗？这是抑郁吗？是其他医疗问题吗？是药物引起的吗？这是一个过程。但如果某人确实患有失眠症，那么午睡实际上是禁忌的。因为对于真正失眠的人，你想做的是积累睡意，这样他们晚上才能入睡。但对于我们其他人来说，
What about naps? Do you think are naps beneficial and can they count towards your night's sleep? Okay. So naps are a little bit tricky because if you do suffer from insomnia and that is a whole diagnostic thing, we do need to sort of make sure are you, is this insomnia? is this anxiety, is this depression, is it some other medical issue, is it mere medication? And that's a process. But if someone is really suffering from insomnia, then I, the naps are actually counterindicated. Because what you want to do with someone who really has insomnia is build up their sleepiness so that they fall asleep at night. But for the rest of us, it's
午睡是可以的。事实上，我认为很多研究表明，短时间的午睡——我指的是20到30分钟的午睡——有助于提高警觉性和能量。我的意思是，地中海地区的人们几千年来一直在午睡。所以，有很多数据表明在下午，即下午早些时候小睡一会儿是一件好事。我会说要避免长时间的午睡，有些人如果躺下午睡，结果变成了两小时的午睡。那也不是一件好事。因为对某些人来说，当你从午睡中醒来时，那是你的一天重新开始的时候。然后这会把你的上床时间推迟。然后你那天晚上可能就睡不好了。这可能会引发一个糟糕的循环，
fine to have a nap. In fact, I think a lot of research has shown that a short nap, and what I mean by short nap is 20 to 30 minute nap, you know, helps improve alertness and energy. I mean, the Mediterranean people have been taking siestas for, for eons. So, you know, there's a lot of data there that taking a short nap in the afternoon, the early afternoon is a good thing. I would say avoiding long naps, and some people do, if they slide down for a nap, it ends up being a two-hour nap. That's actually not a good thing either. Because for some people, that's when your day starts over from the beginning, when you wake up from that nap. And then that's going to push your bedtime later. And then you're going to not maybe have good sleep that night. And that can start a bad cycle
如果你午睡时间很长的话。但短时间的午睡非常好。是的，我确实曾经轮过班，我做过早班。起初，我根本找不到好的睡眠时间表。所以我会在下午午睡，然后晚上就很难入睡。这是一个恶性循环，直到最后我说：“好吧，不午睡了”，除了周五，因为我周一到周五都在轮那个班。所以我做的是回家后保持清醒，特别是周一很难，因为那是周末刚结束。然后就在晚上7:30左右上床睡觉。是的。
if you have a very long nap. But short naps are very good. Yeah, I definitely, I've worked some shifts before where I worked an early morning shift. And at first, I just could not figure out a good sleeping schedule. So I would take a nap in the afternoon and then I have a hard time sleeping at night. It was kind of a vicious cycle until eventually I said, okay, no naps, except for Fridays, because I worked on that shift Monday through Friday. So what I would do is come home and just stay awake, especially Mondays were hard because it was coming off a weekend. And then just go to bed at like 730, PM. Yeah.
这似乎奏效了。没错。没错。但这很难，因为在某些日子里保持清醒非常有挑战性。我只是想午睡。但当我那样做时，它会完全打乱我的身体。是的，确实会。
And that seemed to work. Exactly. Exactly. But it is hard because it was very challenging to stay awake some of those days. I just wanted to take a nap. But then when I would do that, it would throw my body off completely. Yeah. It can.
我的意思是，它只是让你的日子从零开始。就好像那是你醒来的时候。是的。是的。但短时间的午睡。我的意思是，近年来有很多关于这个的研究和讨论。我确实告诉我的客户，比如：你能在白天小睡20分钟吗？是的，能量小睡（Power nap）。是的，能量小睡。太棒了。是的，那总是能帮我……
I mean, it just starts your day from zero. It's as though that's when you woke up. Yeah. Yeah. But a short nap. I mean, there's been a lot of research and a lot of talk about this in recent years. And I do, I do tell my clients, like, can you just take like a 20 minute nap in the middle of day. Yeah, power nap. Yeah, power nap. That's awesome. Yeah, that always helps me
一点点，只是为了……我实际上可能会睡着五分钟左右。我醒来，但我通常感觉好多了。所以能量小睡。我知道不是每个人都能做到，但如果你能，它很有帮助。是的。是的。所以你的人生中会有一些时候，睡个好觉很可能是一个挑战。我们触及了其中的几个，比如在人生压力大的时候，也许是失业、父母去世，或者有了新宝宝，而我目前正处于这个阶段。所以睡眠经常成为挑战几乎是不可避免的。那么在这些人生变动时期，你能做些什么来睡个好觉呢？鉴于这些情有可原的……
a little bit just to kind of like, I'll actually fall asleep maybe for five minutes or something. I wake up, but I usually feel a lot better. So power naps. I know the, not everyone can do them, but if you can, it's helpful. Yeah. Yeah. So there are times in your life when sleeping well is likely going to be a challenge. And we would touch on a little bit of a few of those, like, you know, during a stressful time in your life, maybe a job loss, a death of a parent, or with new baby, and that's something I'm currently in right now. And so it's pretty much unavoidable that sleep is going to be a challenge on a regular basis. So what can you do to sleep well during these life change times? How can you get the best sleep possible given these extenuating
情况，你怎样才能获得尽可能好的睡眠？是的。我的意思是，谁没有经历过你所描述的那段时期呢？有了孩子或处理某种压力大的生活状况。这确实会影响你的睡眠。所以我们必须能够适应生活中这个新的压力源。而且，适应压力被称为“韧性”。所以我们必须真正能够建立我们的韧性来应对这些时期。有几件事有助于建立韧性。那就是沟通。
circumstances? Yeah. I mean, who hasn't had that period of time exactly what you're describing, having a baby or dealing with some stressful life situation. And that's, it is going to affect your sleep. And so we have to be able to adapt to this new stressor in our lives. And, you know, adapting to stress is called resilience. So we have to really be able to build up our resilience to deal with those periods. And one of the things that are several things help build resilience. And that's communication.
所以如果你睡眠不足，你真的想沟通你的需求，特别是像有了新宝宝，也许你们轮流在晚上醒来，轮流处理压力情况。你必须真正设定良好的界限，比如如果事情压力很大。同样，这就像不要在睡前回复压力大的邮件，不要在睡前进行压力大的谈话。所以你要在你能做到的范围内围绕这些设定界限。并真正寻找你可以获得睡眠的机会。就像我们谈到的午睡。如果你需要午睡，就午睡。你的身体可以成为这方面的向导。还有就是设定现实的期望。你知道，这可能只是……你可能只是……
So you want to really communicate what you're needing if you're not getting enough. sleep and you're having, especially like with a new baby, maybe you take turns, waking at night, take turns kind of dealing with the stressful situation. You have to really set good boundaries, like if it's something really stressful. Again, this is like don't answer stressful emails right before going to bed, don't have a stressful conversation right before going to bed. So you set boundaries around that to the extent that you can. And really looking for opportunities when you can get some sleep. Like we talked about naps. If you if you need a nap, take a nap. Your body can be a guide for that. And also just setting realistic expectations. You know, this just may not be, you may just be
在一段时间内走路时会更累一点。不要再向前迈出三、四或十步，让自己因为那个而感到焦虑和不安。这可能只是：目前情况就是这样。而且它不会永远持续下去。只是暂时的。所以真的要围绕焦虑、围绕对失去睡眠的态度设定界限。但如果能睡觉，一定要确保自己去睡觉，而不是回复邮件或打扫浴室，或者……是的，绝对是这样。或者像查看你的社交媒体动态，你知道，如果你的宝宝睡着了，医生总是说，那时候就去午睡。
walking around a little bit more tired for a little while. And to not take another, you know, three or four or ten steps forward and saying, you know, making yourself anxious and upset about that. It might just be, this is the way it is for now. And it's not going to be, it's not going to be forever. It's just for now. So really setting a boundary around the, even the anxiety, around the attitudes about losing sleep. But really making sure if you can get sleep, that you do get sleep, you know, instead of answering emails or cleaning the bathroom or, you know, yeah, absolutely. Or, you know, or like checking your social media feed, you know, if your baby's asleep, the doctors always say, take a nap then.
没错。所以只要意识到，也许这是你人生中需要把睡眠置于其他事情之上的时期。同时，你可能需要意识到它偶尔会供应不足，但我认为拥有这种心态可能有助于缓解你的焦虑，而不是走向极端的灾难化，说“我再也睡不着了”。没错。因为那非常……那可能会让你陷入恶性循环。
Right. So just being aware that, you know, perhaps this is a time in your life where sleep needs to take precedent over other things. At the same time, you might need to just realize that it might be in short supply, you know, occasionally, but just I think having that mentality might be helpful in terms of calming your anxiety instead of going to the extreme catastrophizing saying, I'm never going to sleep again. Exactly. Because that's very, you know, and that would probably set you up for a vicious cycle.
没错。所以只要意识到，也许这是你生命中需要将睡眠置于其他事情之上的时期。同时，你可能需要意识到睡眠偶尔会不足，但我认为拥有这种心态有助于缓解你的焦虑，而不是走向极端的灾难化思维，说“我再也睡不着了”。确实如此。因为那很可能会让你陷入恶性循环。
So yeah, that's a good way of looking at it, just saying this isn't forever, this is the time period right now. I'm going to make sleep a priority over other things and here's how I'm going to do it is helpful. Yeah. And, you know, and talk to the people in your life about what you need and try to negotiate. how to get a little bit more of a little bit more sleep if that's what it is. So if you do work an overnight shift or some kind of shift work that involves you being up, you know, the graveyard shift as it's often called, how can you get the optimal amount of sleep
没错，这是一个很好的看待方式，只要告诉自己这不是永久的，这只是当下的一个阶段。我打算把睡眠放在比其他事情更优先的位置，并且我知道该怎么做，这很有帮助。是的。而且，你知道，要和你生活中的人谈谈你的需求，试着协商一下，看看如果需要的话，如何能多争取一点睡眠时间。所以，如果你确实是在上夜班，或者从事某种需要你保持清醒的轮班工作，也就是常说的“坟墓班”，你该如何获得最佳的睡眠量呢？
when you're in that situation? That is always going to be a challenge. And I have actually worked with a few people over the years who've had that kind of not just the graveyard shift, but the shifts that. that rotate are the worst. Yeah. So, you know, like, it'd be one thing if you work every day from 11 p.m. to 7 a.m. or something, then you could adjust your lifestyle around that.
当你处于那种情况下时？那总是一个挑战。多年来，我确实和一些人共事过，他们不仅要上“坟墓班”，而且还要轮班，那是最糟糕的。是的。所以，你知道，如果你每天晚上11点到早上7点工作，那是一回事，那样你就可以围绕这个时间表调整你的生活方式。
But if you're doing that for three weeks and then doing another shift for the next three weeks and so on, that's actually that has been shown to have severe health consequences. But even more, the psychological consequences of that kind of thing are, things that we, you know, we've just been talking about like depression, anxiety, even dark, dark thoughts, you know, because you just feel bad all the time. But if that's your life, you know, and you can't do anything about it, how can you adapt to that? Well, again, we're going to, you know, this is a stressful situation. So you're going to listen to your body even more than you may think you should. take opportunities to rest or to have naps when you can.
但如果你连续三周这样做，然后接下来的三周又换成另一个班次，以此类推，这实际上已经被证明会带来严重的健康后果。但更重要的是，这种事情带来的心理后果，正如我们刚才讨论的，比如抑郁、焦虑，甚至黑暗的想法，因为你总是感觉很糟糕。但如果这就是你的生活，而且你对此无能为力，你该如何适应呢？好吧，再说一次，这是一个充满压力的环境。所以你要比你想象中更要倾听自己的身体。有机会就休息，或者在可能的时候小睡一会儿。
Light therapy, if you really need to shift back and forth, like let's say you have children and you need to kind of adapt to their schedule on the weekends, but they go back to your work schedule. That might mean that on the weekends, when you don't want to be awake, you might need to be sort of mindful of being in bright light, sort of maybe even shifting your eating, schedule so that your metabolism kind of shifts a little bit too. And then a nap, if you have to be awake at a time when you would normally be asleep, I think like you did, you take a, you take a nap, and then you can then go on with the next half of your day if you need to be awake.
光照疗法，如果你真的需要来回切换，比如你有孩子，周末需要适应他们的作息，但工作日又要回到你的工作时间表。这意味着在周末，当你不想保持清醒时，你可能需要注意避免强光，甚至可能需要调整你的饮食时间表，让你的新陈代谢也随之稍微改变。然后，如果你必须在通常应该睡觉的时间保持清醒，我想就像你做的那样，小睡一会儿，然后如果你需要保持清醒，就可以继续你剩下半天的工作。
It seems like a theme that's sort of we've discussed is really making sleep a priority and making it more of an integral part of your everyday life, no matter what situation you're in. Absolutely. You know, sleep is not optional. Sleep is not a luxury. Sleep is a necessity. And yet a lot of people live for years and years with just getting five or six hours of sleep and they get used to it and think that that's normal until it really doesn't feel normal at all. And do you have any tips for traveling if you jet lag? I mean, there's also a lot of jobs where people travel and they're doing international travel. So then they're dealing with that. How can you manage jet lag and try to get yourself adjusted to the new schedule well? Or do you stay on your old, you know, where you came from? What suggestions? Yeah. Well, if you're going to go to a different time zone for just a couple days, you might not be able to do much about that. You just sort of power through those, you know, those 48 hours of meeting, but if you're going on a vacation for a week or 10 days, you can start actually shifting your body clock to the new time zone a couple of days in advance. And it's going to be hard, but that might mean forcing yourself to wake up at five in the morning instead of seven in the morning.
我们讨论的主题似乎真的是把睡眠放在首位，无论你处于什么情况，都要让它成为你日常生活不可或缺的一部分。绝对是这样。你知道，睡眠不是可选项。睡眠不是奢侈品。睡眠是必需品。然而，许多人多年来只睡五六个小时，他们习惯了，认为这是正常的，直到它真的感觉一点也不正常。你对旅行时有时差反应有什么建议吗？我的意思是，也有很多工作需要人们出差，进行国际旅行。所以他们要处理这个问题。你如何应对时差，并试着让自己适应新的时间表呢？或者你保持原来的作息？有什么建议吗？是的。好吧，如果你只是去不同的时区待几天，你可能做不了太多。你只能硬撑过那48小时的会议，但如果你要去度假一周或十天，你可以提前几天开始调整你的生物钟到新的时区。这会很困难，但这意味着强迫自己在早上五点而不是七点起床。
If you can do that, you can really improve your chances of having a smoother or having less jet lag and a smoother transition to the new time zone. I think they say it's easier to fly west than to fly east because you can always stay up later. Yeah. And, you know, people can tend to be able to stay up later more easily than to wake up earlier. But let's say you are planning to fly east, five, six, seven time zones. If you can force yourself to wake up earlier an hour or two, like a week leading, into the trip, you'll really help yourself. Also, shifting your, again, your eating and your sort of
如果你能做到这一点，你真的可以提高自己减少时差反应、更平稳地过渡到新时区的机会。我想人们常说向西飞比向东飞更容易，因为你总是可以晚点睡。是的。而且，你知道，人们往往比早起更容易晚睡。但假设你计划向东飞，跨越五、六、七个时区。如果你能在旅行前的一周强迫自己早起一两个小时，这对你真的会有帮助。此外，再次强调，调整你的饮食和你的白天活动水平，将这些调整到你即将前往的时区。
daytime activity, you know, activity level shifting those into the time zone that you're going to. Yeah. The other suggestion that's worked for me is just sort of managing it and just maybe trying to keep yourself up to the nighttime wherever you're going and then just sleeping. Yeah. Every long time. It's hard, though. It's really hard. It's much easier to say what the, you know, how to do it, then it is to do it. You can't force yourself to go to bed at 8 p.m. if you're used to going to bed at 11 p.m.
是的。另一个对我有效的建议是管理它，试着让自己保持清醒直到你目的地当地的夜间时间，然后睡觉。是的。每次都很长。但这很难。这真的很难。说起来容易做起来难。如果你习惯了晚上11点睡觉，你无法强迫自己晚上8点就上床睡觉。
It's hard to do that. Yeah, exactly. So sort of like, you know, either try it, maybe even adjust a little bit before or just wait until you're there and then just force yourself to stay up for a while. Your first day and on your vacation might be a little challenging, but then hopefully you can get a good night's sleep. So we've offered some really great tips about sleep. And to sum this all up, it's that sleep is not optional.
这很难做到。是的，完全正确。所以，要么试着在去之前稍微调整一下，要么等到你到了那里，然后强迫自己保持清醒一段时间。你度假的第一天可能会有点挑战，但希望之后你能睡个好觉。所以我们提供了一些关于睡眠的非常好的建议。总结一下，睡眠不是可选项。
I like how you said that because I think you said a lot of people like, you know, we usually a lot, most of us usually don't skimp on eating and doing other things, but like we do on sleep. But as you've said, sleep is a necessity. It's not optional and we need to make that more of a primary part of our everyday life. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, it's flu season. Sleep helps you with your immune system. It's not that it just feels bad when you're sleepy.
我喜欢你这么说，因为我认为你说很多人，你知道，我们通常大多数人通常不会在饮食和其他事情上吝啬，但我们在睡眠上却会。但正如你所说，睡眠是必需品。它不是可选项，我们需要让它成为我们日常生活的主要部分。是的，绝对是。我的意思是，现在是流感季节。睡眠有助于增强你的免疫系统。不仅仅是因为睡眠不足会让你感觉糟糕。
it makes you sick and it makes you, gives you less energy to deal with the stresses of life and gives you less emotional ability to regulate your emotions and to think clearly and to concentrate. There's just a whole host of things. Absolutely. Thank you so much for your time, Dr. Hayd. Really appreciate it. It was my pleasure. If you have any comments or ideas to share, send us an email to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word.org. And also please consider giving us a rating in iTunes.
它会让你生病，让你没有精力去应对生活的压力，让你调节情绪的能力变弱，让你无法清晰思考和集中注意力。还有很多其他问题。非常感谢您的时间，Hayd博士。真的很感激。这是我的荣幸。如果您有任何意见或想法要分享，请发送电子邮件至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，所有单词连在一起.org。也请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcast. You can also go to our website speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的Caitlin Luna。感谢收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。